ach so ja das mag ein bisschen
dabei geht es mir um deine nach
deutschland und herzlich willkommen zu
neuen video
heute möchte ich mal mit euch mit matt
und mit dem totenkopf here are zeit je
eine zeitreise machen und zwar zurück
ins jahr 2013 sagen wir jetzt jahr 2013
wird erst mal ein ganz klassisches
gesetz bleibe machen ohne klick bei
titel ohne hektischen schnitt ohne
challenges ohne hacker ohne also
hoffentlich und hacker was hier in der
runde machen weiß ich nicht aber einfach
mal ganz große wie das früher gemacht
hat vor zwei jahren einfach mal hier
seine runde durch spielen und gerne mal
eure meinung dazu einfangen euch fragen
was ihr davon haltet den maxi übrigens
noch dabei und damit die runde ein
bisschen aufgepeppt wird nämlich alle
ganz ehrlich ich hätte man richtig bock
ich selbst hätte richtig bock mir so ein
altes klassisches let's play mal
anzuschauen von einem der eigentlich
mittlerweile anders tag nach deutschland
ist vollkommen unglaublich eigentlich
warum wie und wieso ist unlogisch
bestimmt
wir machten so was und das auch
dauerhaft zu machen es war schon richtig
kran sein
verstehste nein ich habe eigentlich
unlogisch also ach so ja also was der
ecke kann
ok naja ok auf jeden fall ich hab noch
auf twitter hashtag beschreibt question
da habe ich euch gebeten fragen und
themen für dieses video bisschen
vorzuschlagen
damit wir das quasi ganz im klassischen
sinne des austauschs zwischen klima und
genau
community machen können und der max ist
mit dabei noch so kann das wir
eigentlich nur noch bei werden hier
schön jumping versuche ein bisschen
skill aufs parkett zu legen wird mehr
oder weniger klappen denke ich mal okay
markschies los wird ohne frage ist was
war in diesem jahr umfasst dieses jahr
erschien beantworten ich tue mich immer
ein bisschen schwer
lieblingslied ja ich würde sagen pages
pages soll ich sagen habe ich auch viel
gehört also pages kam habe ich heute
erst gehört dass page von zaun leute
irgendwie so glaubte man verwirrt das
solid dass es unter heizung aber da kann
man auch inhaltlich dahinter stehen
ansonsten ich hätte aber auch irgendwie
sowas schon wieder was war das war
gerade letztens war das hast du auch auf
jeden fall schon viel gehört
wer weiß in welchem interpret ist welche
richtung es geht
aber ich glaube ich nicht mehr was echt
ne kann man aber auch das war ab und
verlieren das ist mir zu prollig auf
dauer was ich cool fand
dies ja weil ich auch gute erinnerung
daran habe ist dass dieses mega
fröhliche liefern so ein konstant
inkonstant weil coole erinnerung weil es
soll den ich ja schon ewig feier und so
hat mich dann einfach da vor ort wurde
angeschrieben munro bis schon mal
reinhören kannst du dir dann teil wenn
du bock drauf hast und dass man hier
erfolg größer weil meine
lieblingsmusiker das ist schon geil und
ich hätte ausziehen in der zeit war
einfach eigentlich alles ziemlich ein
freund urlaub
warna gepasst ich war einfach maxis
freundin wir zusehen dass maxis freundin
aber wer ist es jetzt die frage also
lassen sie mal raus wer hat eigentlich
alles gepasst und deshalb habe ich da
eine gute wahl
in verbindung mit dem lied ich überlegt
die ganze zeit welche sieht das war dass
sich eure sicherung man wollte letztens
was jay rock zufällig die leute wenn es
nicht kennt heute ich mal an of the box
also unorthodox notfalls google wie man
schreibt auf spotify von jobware das
anders tesch it's okay vielleicht auch
das vielleicht von der teams von laurie
mathers oder antrieb ist aber vielleicht
auch pages von soll
okay okay so alt ist wird noch eine
weile robert frage was war das beste
weihnachten was ihr je erlebt hat ich
finde weihnachten ist echt immer so ein
bisschen materialistisch und das coolste
fand ich war als ich meinen ipod touch
bekommen hat kann ich voll cool
so ich hätte es niemals für möglich
gehalten vor allen dingen der vorsaison
was mir möglich im internet zu bereiten
und so und dann habe ich halt meinen
ersten ipod touch bekommen hast du
keinen pc davor sollte ihm mit im
internet ja klar wohin mein mann dann
ist ja immer so halben stunde aber
stimmt also an limitiert internetsucht
jaguar consorten du konntest einfach mit
einem ersten persönlichen gerät was du
unlimitiert zur verfügung hat und wenn's
auf äpfel hängen geblieben und
nachvollziehbarer weise bin ich aber
auch leute kann man kann man schon
feiern was war damals ein gut zu
weihnachten ein kurzes weihnachten
ich fahre ich kann nicht ich fand aber
weiß ja irgendwie cool dass man halt
selbst möglichkeiten hatte dick was zu
geben und leuten freude sie dank youtube
kann man die dieses jahr wo ich mir
selbst geschenke machen
letztes jahr mit neuen finanziellen ruin
getrieben leuten weihnachts geschenk
mitzubringen so dieses jahr
lesen sie mal nicht kann ich nach denkt
und redet er erkannt dass mein
weihnachten besten gefallen ich weiß
nicht ich musste gerade daran denken
dass wir das war damals ein tischkicker
bekommen haben das war auch dinger ich
glaube hängiger feuer das hoffe das war
classic alter das war herr lebenswerk
schon cool original
der bgh hatte nikam tabea nicht an
weihnachten
15.12 aber ja ich jemals den namen
gesagt ja das ist meine schwester die
kam 15 er ja wann kam die zu uns es muss
auch um weihnachten gewesen sein
ja das war daran muss sich heute denken
habe ich nicht mit dir über geräte sowie
das damals zu uns kommen
das war das war ein lustiger tag werde
ich kann ich mal die story erzählen
jetzt folgt persönlich aber okay und
zwar im wallis sonntag da hatten wir
meine eltern aus welchem grund auch
immer ich glaube weil sie da ihre
kleinen neugeborenes ins haus holen
wollten erlaubt den ganzen tag lang
siedler zu spielen hier damals siedler
gesucht heute siedler habe ich gesucht
alter so habe ich kein spiel gesucht
jetzt bist ja mit austria.at also hab
ich kein spiel gesagt glaube ich ja ja
die sucht man ja ok fifa wie auch noch
krasser gesuchte aber sieht da habe ich
schon richtig krass gesuchte dann haben
wir meine eltern mit damals zehn jahren
erlaubt einfach mal so den ganzen tag
lange siedler zu spielen ich das so jo
ich bin im himmel haben so gemeint soja
kommt wenn wir jetzt einen ganzen tag
lang spielen lassen dann wird ihm
langweilig dann gewöhne sich das ab dann
bekommt er zu viel
wir haben keine ahnung haben wir den
ganz natürliche besuchten abends kam
eine hat es draußen schneit und dann hat
es geklingelt und dann kamen die un
hatten in seinem körbchen insm babytrage
ihr wisst wie ich meine
also dieses neutrale für babys hatten
sie dann eine kleine schwester dabei
übersieht siedler war der hammer walter
sittler ich habe gar nicht gesagt welche
die siedler gold edition damals mit den
trojanern
das war cool heute habe ich das gesuchte
das würde ich jederzeit wieder spielend
weiß ob jetzt auch gespielt hat aber das
würde ich jederzeit wieder spielen also
ich hab leider gar keine großen erinnern
daran wer zu uns gekommen irgendwie so
wahrscheinlich seit damals daher glaube
ich und den zeitpunkt zum mord gibt es
an gibt gibt es eigenschaften einem
anderen gar nicht könnt ja positiv bei
sony oder nein sagt das statement zum
genauen alter schwede richtig klaus hog
mich alter ich würde sagen die neigung
von max mir irgendwie vorzuschreiben was
zu machen habe du weißt worauf ich ein
spiel
du weißt brauche ich an spielen
du weißt worauf ich an spiele macht es
mir darauf dass mir so ein bisschen aber
dabei geht es mir um deinen bohlen
deutschland schlagen
müsste 33 ist schwierig also manchmal
habe ich das gefühl dass du ein bisschen
viel verlangt
ich war das zu viel verlangt vielleicht
teilt also teilweise ein bisschen
unverhältnismäßig okay grundsätzlich so
kommt sämtliche angelegenheiten klopft
an der tür ist dabei was tut ihr
erschießen soll ich noch alles sein
max max markt sollte mich jemand sind da
die verwandeln brähmig irgendwie geil
hatte die stärke wenn du dich zwischen
nie wieder kein internet youtube ist
schon ganz nach alter spart natürlich
macht es würde für mats ist wäre keine
schlechte er schwere entscheidung
erlebnissen schlachten sind ja lustig
war volkert versuchen wenigstens eine
einwendung einzuschleichen
da habe ich ihn sehr schön die 0 lässt
in diesem fall ist das doch gar kein
deathmatch wenn ich nicht gestorben bin
ja a
wenn ich es auch nicht auch nicht schon
dann habt ihr es leute rein und schreibt
in die kommentare 3 + 3